hello and welcome to this video playing
led learn that that's that's a new
opponent right yeah and when he has a
couple of games in so quite a quite a
bigger rating there 585 okay it's a
pastor with this Italian games now the
heck is that dog doing I'm playing chess
ear ok this is night a three it's beyond
me and it would understand this idea
okay I always think that this is struck
absolutely nothing I'm probably not
understanding it right
so it's going at will be three or what
is the deal probably
before 96 I might go back yeah I have to
do something with the other night and c6
lighter sir oh it's a bit of an issue
there okay night will come to see 5 here
also Queenie 6 is 95
yeah what is better here and that's it i
don't understand it i don't understand
those positions really don't
hey I can go be 66 takes Knight eggs
yeah I'm not happy with taking this but
I cannot avoid it so here of course if
I've hangs but maybe I can get some cowl
to play with this b6 stuff or just
create it looks pretty awful ok fp6
around the corner
yeah okay a knight is six foot is it all
that terrible top if I take as root deep
voice and it's got queen to g6 that's
the biggest issue actually lads before I
cannot I cannot even take it wow I can't
take it maybe look at saying only one k
zone mr. out for c4
okay of course why it's bad out me maybe
I can stab some some kind of trouble
here but up to this point he plays it I
mean very very strong so 94 95 might
come this is also strong check time
warning okay black resigns Joe tough
tough to have beam yeah I cannot play
those positions well I just think this
is like absolutely nothing and then
slowly but surely I get some problems
it's based on the knight on c6 is of
course not particularly particularly
strong piece weighs somewhat worse
didn't even defend this that he'll
believe it it's just very very strong c4
okay I was going through a little bit
because the new account is always
suspicious and this is this kind of
power player reeks a little bit like
engine but it isn't he just played a
very strong game he hit mr. quite a
couple of opportunities to even kill the
quicker so it wasn't a computer it was
just a very strong human play yeah I
don't really know it's always a little
bit of a problem here this piece on c69
maybe I can regroup it somewhat
differently I don't really see how
exactly this is probably ultimately
costs time now the screen see files done
damn channel it also has night to c5 and
this is very annoying hmm then I don't
have a good position man yeah probably
have to rethink the way I'm playing this
opening I play and played in a somewhat
simple kind of simple fashion and I
don't know the subtleties against
someone who really knows what it's doing
I get into trouble quite an odd okay
thanks for watching